welcome back to cbs mornings now at 7 30
and as the war in ukraine grinds on the
government in kiev is accusing russia of
a truly heinous crime
kidnapping thousands of children and
taking them into russian-controlled
territory ukraine says russia is trying
to force the children to become russian
chris livesay has the extraordinary
story now of two young boys who after
being rescued were brought back to
ukraine
their music is ukrainian
their clothes are ukrainian
but maxine and yvonne were almost forced
to become russian
[Music]
russian forces took us away says 16 year
old yvonne he and 15 year old maxime
were living in an orphanage in mariupol
when russia invaded the boys tried to
flee but say they were captured by
russian forces and held with 20 other
children some as young as eight were you
afraid that you would never come home
yeah
i had such thoughts yes
says russia is systematically stealing
their children and stripping them of
their identities russia continues its
kidnapping of ukrainian children
after forcible transfer to russia they
are illegally adopted by russian
citizens
russian tv says they're saving them
instead
here's russia's children's rights
commissioner telling vladimir putin that
russian citizens have big hearts and are
lining up to take the children
very good he says vowing to eliminate
any delays
it's cynical propaganda says ukrainian
vice prime minister irina varuschuk
we're talking about children whose
parents have possibly been killed by
russians and now these children
are in russia as a ukrainian and as a
mother how does this make you feel
it's very hard she says it's my destiny
to bring them home
and she's doing it one by one helping
relatives and guardians track down their
children and negotiating their return
many with unfathomable trauma
when one 12 year old girl had to dig a
hole to bury her mother
[Music]
they tried to bury her brother too but
his corpse was too heavy for them to
drag
i've seen small children whose hair has
turned white
yet such children like yvonne and maxime
are the lucky ones who have escaped
thanks to anton ballet their guardian
from the orphanage in marieuple
[Music]
saving them meant crossing into enemy
territory not through the deadly front
line but through poland lithuania latvia
and russia 70 hours of travel by bus he
arrived just before dawn
i was still sleeping says maxine when i
saw anton i hugged him i was so happy we
had not seen each other for so long
after more than two months in captivity
they're now back in ukraine yvonne
messages his friend philip an abducted
ukrainian orphan like him but unrescued
he's been sent to an orphanage in moscow
do you still want to come home to
ukraine he texts it's all the same
philip responds like so many ukrainian
children he has no one left to come home
to
for cbs mornings chris livesay kamninsky
ukraine
boy that's just trauma on top of trauma
first you're without your parents and
then you're ripped away from people that
you know and love that could possibly
take care of you then your identity
stripped away yeah yeah you don't need a
u.n convention to tell you that's wrong
that's right and it appears to just be
the way russia fights wars these days
wrong on so many levels tony